a biggest hack ever knew hmmmmmm
submitted by ever thought about living
in a giant mushroom not really oh now a
massive cyberattack held computers for
ransom worldwide dun-dun-duh how that's
what I'm scared you know they always
talk about like how they can tap into
your computer and freakin hijack your
camera yeah it will started taking that
stuff I can't mine
that's guarantee what people hijack your
computers and they steal all my art you
know I be making masterpieces and stuff
Oh y'all Odie he's [ __ ] though this is
crazy dude fill this in here
I got art yeah but a duck you did this
all guys just to put it up it go duck
yourself my dad [ __ ] my book hmm some
mates lost the world was hit with the
biggest attack in the history of all of
the Internet 153 countries were affected
by this attack well over 300,000
computers are targeted and so this I
protect they're calling it the wanna cry
they were attacked and so what happens
is these hackers they use a tool that
was developed by the NSA here in the US
which somehow got leaked out and so
apparently the NSA discovered a weakness
in Microsoft and so instead of telling
Microsoft what the NSA did is they
developed this tool in order to hack
like terrorist computers and things like
that and so it somehow these hackers got
a hold of that tool and just like
release it out and dark web or I don't
know where they release it but they
really set out to other hackers and
that's how this entire cyber attacks
happen Microsoft actually they discover
that they had this weakness and their
programs and so they released they sent
out like a patch for it about two months
ago but a lot of you know house we never
download the updates on most of our
stuff so a lot of people did we just
didn't know yeah so then a lot of these
people they we thought
texts and so what they would see as as
soon as they turn on the computer okay
which the message would pop up oh [ __ ]
Jacob oops your files have been
encrypted what happened to my computer
your important files are encrypted
maybe the whole thing is a lot we got
pretty much is just a sorry I meant like
the title um okay sorry but yes I'm
pretty much to just says like we hacked
your computer
we're holding all your files for ransom
pretty much we could pay three hundred
six hundred dollars and then we'll give
you this key to unlock your computer but
apparently a lot of the people that did
pay the ransom
they still - they haven't gotten the key
so they still can't access their files
and these computers except I got
affected yeah they're estimating that
these hackers have collected over
seventy two thousand dollars that do it
from 150 countries yeah absolutely they
have [ __ ] Chinese people ransom
illios buzzing money come on yeah to
their authority of them or agents we
don't negotiate with terrorists might
play nice five these are the countries
are like the major ones I got [ __ ] like
in the US it was see look China that's
why I don't like I don't care exactly
I'm not gonna pay nice quiet oh it was
everyone from Germany UK and US that
paid probably yeah
so the u.s. FedEx deliveries were
disrupted the UK their health care
system a lot of hospitals you had to
cancel like emerge like surgeries and
like they can't access medical records
again I'm not such it was just by
hacking guys yeah and then in Germany
like the railway ticket machines were
down in Russia a thousand government
computers were hacked like just
everywhere I don't know they use
Microsoft in Russia people get afraid to
use like all these technologically
advanced vehicles yeah well if your car
gets hacked and then I'll suddenly drive
you right off the [ __ ] bridge that's
why I use the trusty really good old
legs
my good ol days and you can't [ __ ]
hack me leg [ __ ] that's what a lot of
experts are saying to protect your files
and to protect yourself from possible
hack to always back up their stuff on an
offline I need extra stuck at everybody
says but we don't do it like [ __ ] it
match has a time machine thing we're
supposed to backup all your father into
a second hard drive I have yet to do it
I used to do it back in the day I should
do it too but now I don't give a [ __ ]
you know why now you need tonight no no
I need to mom you know why because
everything is here not the computer I
know he almost post your own eyes it's
just so much files to back up man not if
you own a but if you keep doing it every
month it's like how many files you know
what's a stake to that hole password
shipped out you have to make like they
keep making the password more and more
complicated like you got to have a
capital capital like a special character
and a number and a letter when we got
hacked I was able to contact one of the
hackers because he's actually a fan and
he got is like great have black hair
whatever there's a special hat or
something they had and then so when
they're hacking they're not hacking at
the personal level they're not going Oh
tips mail you know they're hacking
servers so you all the passwords that
we're creating it doesn't do jack [ __ ]
they have to server so if that server is
part of Chase Bank they have the
information for everybody in Chase and
now they just go in and they have
everyone's account so like I don't even
know why they make our passwords so
complicated because it's a waste of a
time for hackers to hack one person at a
time it's just [ __ ] annoying to every
too much I have a password there like by
the way use a capital letter use an
exclamation point and I asterisk and
then a number and then make sure it's
low case and application like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah and then if you change your
password and if it's too close they
won't they also allow it I just want to
use my original password password sent a
real password you should change it now
like yet you can't it's not possible you
have to be like password exclamation
exclamation two four five or something
yeah you can you can write passing you
can use [ __ ] like that anymore
ridiculous so this attack when it
happened it was spreading so far and
wide and fast okay it was an accidental
solution though so this 22 year old
named Marcus aka malware tech he noticed
that there was a malware connected to an
unregistered website or domain name and
so what he did is he registered it for
like less than eleven dollars and that
activated a kill switch and just stopped
the that is funny
he just bought a domain and it does it
mm-hmm he's not that's crazy how a
domain fix everything I'm a hacker I
want to know how to do the Hat well I
mean the way that we got hacked with all
of our YouTube channels is they hacked
our the network that all of us were tied
to and then that's that's how they
changed all of our titles but they
couldn't do other things I think they
actually had the server that our
networks attached to yeah so they
changed all of our titles that we
couldn't do anything we changed our
passwords or whatever that titles just
kept changing and changing and I was
like this is like more work because it
hacked into people's PayPal and also
Amazon accounts and also my face so so
our network and all those other things
were just all part of the server so they
hacked the server and then it's like
this huge like avalanche effect it's not
that you're not special David she was so
sad you extracted you want uh you want
on the elite celebrity server that were
part I don't want to get hacked at all I
think it's just crazy to me how how do
you do that stuff but I want to know it
is pretty nice not that I would do it
for fun ya know just going out through
like the early early hackers like back
in like the 90s in the eighteen I'm like
hygiene expert you know how to [ __ ]
do that stuff I just used um so on AOL
the way I would crack passwords is I
will go into people's oh yeah you are a
hack now
no I wasn't that good but I I would just
I was just basically going to their
account profile and then I would write
down everything that did this person's
password might be and I would just sit
there manually what a loser
how much time well no it's not a loser
because I would have free accounts that
way I don't mean yes ton of time of
course I was like 12 no I was like 13 13
years are losers that's good to be your
kid too much I know
[ __ ] loser serious well basically
what we would do is we would get into
these master accounts and then we could
create new accounts that they don't know
that are aware and then we don't have to
pay for internet service so good yeah
and that's why you can't have passwords
like password and then it sucks because
then it has to be so complicated with
upper/lower dashes and [ __ ] on number
but not at the end somewhere in the
third letter and then you're like [ __ ] I
can't remember any of my passwords yeah
that's why you should write all your
password stuff you know about a piece of
paper
nobody could hack [ __ ] papers unless
you lose the paper in here that's what
you have a backup of the piece of paper
second widget attitude on their body but
then you got to change the password then
you gotta scratch out that exact
password that's on the time easy I got
all my passwords on a piece of paper
right now oh yeah you know why because I
used to have it in my phone but I have
this [ __ ] habit of breaking my phone
so I kept not getting [ __ ] over so
I'll put it on a piece of paper now I
can't actually I actually can't even put
it on a piece of paper because my
handwriting sucks so there's gonna be at
least five characters that look the same
favorite and then print it oh yeah smart
I'll even have a planner that's pop
you're like a shambles right now well I
had a personal printer I'm not I'm not
one of those guys that does personal
things with business Kowski yeah that's
how noble yeah you remember back in the
day those [ __ ] printers the [ __ ]
loud a [ __ ] God dude cut off the ends
yeah I love because it was a game so I
would like cut all of them and it was
string and then I would have like
pom-poms oh my god do my dad loser super
[Laughter]
usually you which will be old lose you
hacking you're doing pom-pom bags
it's not that funny I was just talking
on my coffee I don't know if that makes
you a loser is really poor like sad but
but that's what I did you know younger
oh my god girl loser you have [ __ ] to do
everyone huh I don't know anyone that's
actually a winner at 13 you'd be
surprised are those kids look at
inventing [ __ ] but do they have a
girlfriend no because they're losers I'm
so [ __ ] terrible live human being
they're what they do have a girlfriend
we gotta find some nice find something
about them do you [ __ ] [ __ ] as kids
are so [ __ ] lucky
everything you do now is silent as [ __ ]
the printer was loud [ __ ] sound like
your parents though yeah bear apologies
and then they [ __ ] and somebody picks
up the phone while you do get the [ __ ]
off the floor above the internet you
[ __ ] lucky and your printer they put
in [ __ ] bass cuz that [ __ ] was slow
even not even had yeah like a picture
all should instant like this because it
did it did it [ __ ] that [ __ ] what is
this how about downloading music oh my
god dude for once on it would be like an
hour for what three Meg's the first song
I ever downloaded was a song for mama by
boys to men and it took me 30 minutes
yeah well there she's pretty fast and
that was that locally and I used to have
that song on repeat because I was in
wasan I have don't you get hella happy
dude when you get lucky and that book is
song like downloads like 15 minutes I
used to get hyped about looks not good
day where you would let them win the
song that you wanted actually downloaded
without the [ __ ] promo oh yeah
then if you got something like fall some
of us a radio edit could have like no
curse words I wanted to [ __ ] sit on it
you know how it's not old how's it going
guys don't forget to like the video
because if you don't I will break your
[ __ ] legs thank you so much for the
last videos don't forget to click right
here or I'll break your [ __ ] arms
click right here you guys
[Music]